STEPHANIE WONG:
Today we're talking
about Tau VMs, BigQuery
Security, the future
of computing and gaming.
I'm Stephanie Wong, and
welcome to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Scale out workloads
demand the best combo
of performance and
price to bring down
the cost of delivering
applications,
all while providing an
excellent user experience.
We are excited to announce
a new VM family, Tau VMs,
coming to Google Cloud.
Tau VMs extend compute
engines VM offerings
with a new option optimized
for cost-effective performance
of scale out workloads.
We're excited to announce the
GA BigQuery row-level security,
which gives customers
a way to control access
to subsets of data in the same
table for different groups
of users.
Row-Level Security, RLS,
extends the principle
of least privilege access and
enables fine grained access
control policies
in BigQuery tables.
BigQuery currently
supports access controls
at the project, data set,
table, and column level.
Since quantum computing is the
next technological revolution,
and we want to make it
universally accessible,
we're excited to announce that
quantum computers from IonQ
are now available on the
Google Cloud marketplace.
Developers, researchers,
and enterprises
alike can now access IonQ's
high fidelity 11 qubit
system via Google Cloud
in just a few clicks,
with a billing and provisioning
handled via their existing
Google accounts.
With the surge of new gamers
and an increase in time
spent playing games
in the last year,
it's more important than ever
to delight and engage players.
We're here to help you build
high quality experiences
and take your games
to the next level.
Join us for our online
event on July 12 to the 13th
to catch deep dives full of
best practices to help you
continue creating great games,
connecting with players,
and scaling your business.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.